[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue
Laurence arrivet pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste la République
merci monsieur le Président le projet
d'union sacré autour du logement entre
les associations et le gouvernement
peine à faire ses preuves dans un
interview donné au journal Libération ce
4 février monsieur le ministre vous
dénoncez loutrans des associations comme
Utopia 56 ou la Fondation Abbé Pierre
que vous accusez de jouer avec la misère
des gens à travers des actions chocs de
sensibilisation ces associations ne se
contentent pourtant pas d'alerter elle
produisent surtout un travail de fond
chiffré et documentés et elles sont les
seules à le faire ce même 4 février plus
de 20 maires de gauche ont interpellé le
président de la République sur la
situation du mal logement et proposer
cette mesure qui répondent aux besoins
des différents publics en situation de
grande exclusion ma question est très
simple quelle réponse allez-vous leur
faire
pour vous répondre à la parole est au
ministre délégué en charge de la ville
et du Logement Monsieur Olivier Klein
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice Harry Bay
vous avez raison la question du
sans-abrise est une question qui nous
préoccupe tous et sur lequel le
gouvernement agit et agit de manière
historique je le rappelle encore hier
soir c'est plus de 200000 places
d'hébergement d'urgence qui était
ouverte dans ce pays ce chiffre n'avait
jamais été atteint quelle que soit les
gouvernements précédents ces 5,7
millions d'euros qui sont dépensés
chaque soir pour héberger les plus
fragiles et ce n'est que justice le
gouvernement a lancé le plan logement
d'abord 1 et ce plan logement d'abord un
à marché de manière historique là encore
440 000 personnes ont quitté la rue
l’hébergement d'urgence pour avoir un
toit d'ailleurs parmi les maires qui
nous ont interpellé dans le journal il y
a quelques jours plus de la moitié
d'entre eux sont des territoires
d'accélération du plan logement d'abord
1 et je les réuni très régulièrement
notamment pour préparer le plan logement
d'abord 2 et je leur ai proposé de les
recevoir dès demain pour continuer à
travailler avec eux et les propositions
qu'ils font sont celles avec lequel nous
avons discuté il y a quelques jours dans
la préparation du plan logement d'abord
2 ce plan devra continuer à accélérer la
mise à l'abri et je peux vous assurer
que c'est notre priorité comment nous
allons faire et bien en continuant à
construire construire des pensions de
famille construire des résidences
sociales en améliorant l'accompagnement
social des familles parce que il faut
accompagner les familles avant pendant
et après le relogement et ça fait partie
des éléments forts du plan logement
d'abord bien évidemment et pour ceux qui
me connaissent un petit peu la
préoccupation qui sont exprimées par les
maires sont la préoccupation de tous les
maires et de tous les élus qui sont
présents dans cette salle j'amène nous
n'acceptons qu'une famille avec un
enfant soit à la rue jamais nous
n'acceptons en tout cas je l'espère que
ces enfants ne soient pas scolarisés et
ça fera aussi partie de nos priorités et
nous continuerons à les mener ensemble
et j'en parlerai dès demain avec
l'ensemble des sémers merci
j'entends votre réponse monsieur le
ministre et je ne mets pas en cause
votre volonté personnelle et votre
expérience d'élue locale sur cette
question là ce que je mets en cause
c'est une vision globale une politique
globale du logement qui n'existe pas
tant que le logement sera une variable
d'ajustement budgétaire la tribune des
20 maires appelle à déployer en urgence
un plan stratégique national et
transversal répondant à un diagnostic
clair et transparent que le gouvernement
a tout intérêt à produire rapidement ça
éviterait de contester les seuls
chiffres qui existent il n'existe pour
l'heure aucune stratégie globale et je
crois que la vérité n'appartient à
personne la question c'est de savoir si
nous voulons travailler tous ensemble
et ce n'est pas un atelier du Conseil
national de la refondation tout seul qui
va trouver la solution vous avez déclaré
les associations sont mal inspirées
quand elles tombent dans l'outrans j'ai
la modestie et l'humilité de vous dire
qu'un gouvernement est mal inspiré quand
il tombe dans la suffisance ce n'est
certainement pas le meilleur moyen de
co-construire nous nous sommes prêts
ainsi que les vins mers qui vous ont
interpellé de co-construire et très vite
nous proposerons notre groupe une
proposition de loi nous verrons quelle
est la vraie volonté de co-construire
merci
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue trop de
Bourras pour le groupe les républicains
[Musique]